the reasonable man adapts himself to the
world the unreasonable one persists in
trying to adapt the world to himself
therefore all progress depends on the
unreasonable person and to us it
describes the kind of person we're
looking for someone who's just a little
bit crazy enough to think that they
could actually make a difference in the
world
my name is Te'o Evolution I'm 29 years
old I'm co-founder and CEO of
unreasonable Institute my company helps
entrepreneurs who are tackling social
and environmental problems get what they
need to do it and to scale it up so
we're sort of like what medical school
is for doctors for entrepreneurs
tackling poverty or climate change or
access to education across the world
[Music]
my family's from India I was born and
raised the United States and we would go
back to India to visit relatives a lot
once when I was about 10 O's with my dad
in a market in Chennai we're walking
through this market and this little kid
comes up to my dad and asked him for
money and he runs off after my dad gives
him something and asked my dad why is
this kid begging when he seems like he's
my age and my dad says the best answer I
can give you is luck he was born to a
family that doesn't have the means to
take care of him
but you were born to a family that has
the means to take care of you so you've
got to know that everything you have is
is a gift
and you've got to share with other
people over the next few days we saw
more people begging and not a lot of
people were willing to help them and ask
him why and he said most of them don't
know how and I said what do you mean he
said well they may not think that giving
money will work they think there's so
many people who live in poverty there's
nothing they can do about it they don't
know what else to do so they kind of
just ignore it
[Music]
when we started unreasonable Institute
we had no income for 15 months we had no
resources no expertise no exposure we
literally had nothing but a name and an
idea and so I think that was that was
pretty risky but to be honest I wouldn't
have want to spend my time doing
anything else other than figuring out
how we could help people and there were
some ways in which we were reckless and
careless I know now but I can't imagine
a better way to have spent my time when
I was 22
I think the best advice I've I've
received is to clearly define the
problem you're trying to solve spend as
much time as you can trying to
understand the problem you're solving
then run as many experiments as you can
to figure out how to solve that problem
find the bright spots and invest your
resources time and energy in expanding
those bright spots I think that's that's
probably the best advice of them
[Music]